well let's talk about
the thing you've done for over 20 years
which is fight for the freedom of speech
on college campuses uh so why is freedom
of speech important on college campuses
well it's important everywhere in the
society but it's most important that
college campuses why because that's
where we educate our young citizens
and if you are educated
under a notion that some Dean can can
call you on the carpet because you say
something which is considered racist or
you can say something which is uh
considered then you know dangerous to uh
to social cohesion
um then it's not a liberal arts college
now
um the um the theory that
I used in in the shadow University
a book you've written the shadow
Universe 1998
1998. you were ahead of a lot of these
things I'm afraid that as as a pessimist
I always saw the bad side of things
betrayal of Liberty on America's
campuses the shower University the a
book you co-authored with the Alan
Charles yes with one of my Princeton
classmates Alan Charles course who's now
an Emeritus professor of Enlightenment
history at the University of
Pennsylvania
I only taught for one semester and I can
go into that later the reason that I did
not continue to teach in colleges
um it was Harvard Law School I I taught
a course in the mid-1980s
um but in any event
um the college campuses are one of the
most important of all for uh for free
speech because this is where people get
education
and if you don't really get a good
education if certain points of view are
not allowed to be expressed because
education comes from The Clash of ideas
and you then have to decide this is the
this is how you become a thinking adult
you have to decide which ideas make more
sense to you which ones you're going to
follow
um the college experience is
transformative
and if there is censorship on campuses
it's highly destructive of the
educational Enterprise
and ultimately to the entire Society you
know we have in the Sciences
um we have a scientific method
scientific method is you try experiments
and you see which ones work and then you
develop theories based the public
results of experiments well this is not
much different from every other aspect
of life
you have to entertain different views on
different subjects you hear all the
views and you make a decision as to
which one's accurate which one's not
so a scientific method I apply to um to
non-science to history to journalism
um to all of these things so that
scientific method includes ideas hateful
ideas also correct if you don't allow
hateful ideas I mean when scientists do
experiments nobody says to them oh you
know don't don't do that experiment
because it would be a very bad if that
turns out to be accurate you know that
outcome that's not the way it works
um every every point of view is thrown
into the marketplace whether it's
science or whether it's a
you know non-science and that includes
uh the kind of ideas and the kind of
discourse that might actually lead to an
increase in hate on campuses the the the
First Amendment
prohibits speech which is liable to
produce
imminent imminent violence yeah so for
example
um you know the um the exception is um
yelling uh falsely falsely yelling fire
in a crowded movie theater a lot of
people misstate it they say oh
um the exception is yelling fire in a
movie theater if there's really a fire
you're performing a real important
function
but it's falsely yelling fire you can
start a riot people would be crushed try
to get out
so there are these that that's one of
the exceptions that the First Amendment
as the Supreme Court has defined it
um
there are very few exceptions
um and defamation is an exception I'm a
I'm not a fan of that exception frankly
but um if you say something
um about somebody that has serious
implications in their uh in their life
and their ability their own living if
you say accuse somebody of being a
pedophile but it's not true
that person can sue you
um my own view is I think that's an
unfortunate exception but I'm not I'm
the Supreme Court
um uh I think that um I'm I'm with I
a friend of mine was not hentoff
that hand tough who wrote for decades
for the Village Voice in New York
um
he was a friend of mine he was a free
speech absolutist
and uh he wrote a fabulous book called
free speech for me but not for thee
um and he was an absolutist and I'm I'm
with I'm with Matt hentoff even on the
defamation aspect I mean I agree with
you in some sense just practically
speaking it seems like
that the way the best way in the the
public sphere to defend against
deformation is with more speech correct
and through authenticity
authentic communication
um
of the truth as you see it yeah you know
at the Times the Boston Globe has said
something about me that hasn't been
accurate they have invariably published
my letter to the editor
um I'm also uh not bashful about getting
in charge in touch with the reporter
that at the end of every column they
give the reporters email address
um
and I know people say that I I have more
access to the media than most people
um but um all that means is I get to
fame with the most people
can we also comment on from the
individual consumer of speech
there's a kind of uh sense that funeral
speech means you're you should be forced
to read all of it
freedom of speech versus freedom of
reach
we as consumers of speech do we have the
right to select what we read we do and
um that nobody can force us to sit in
the room and listen to a radio program
that we don't want to listen to nobody
can forces to read a book that we don't
want to read
um the whole notion of freedom of speech
means that people have uh autonomy on
their choices in order to form a
complete mind and complete human being
there's a kind of tension
of that autonomy
versus
um consuming as many varied perspectives
as possible which is underlying the
ethic of free speech so on college
campuses
it seems like a good way to develop the
mind is to get as many perspectives as
possible even if you don't really want
to
well that's that is the theory academic
freedom is the is supposed to be the
highest degree of free speech yeah
um you should be able to entertain uh
all kinds of hateful
threatening ideas and and the way I put
it is there's something wrong when you
can say something with complete abandon
without any fear in Harvard Square
whereas on the other side of the fence
you can't say it in Harvard Yard it
should be the opposite